allez on va parler de la réforme des
retraite puisque c'est le jour J pour
l'arrivée de la réforme au Sénat d'abord
Audrey on va voir avec vous puisque tous
les regards se tournent maintenant vers
le Sénat l'examen commence aujourd'hui
comment ça va se passer alors ça
commence cet après-midi la commission
des affaires sociales s'en empare c'est
à ce moment qu'on devrait voir se
dessiner les stratégies des différents
groupes et les amendements déposer il
faudra tout de même aller à la pêche aux
infos car au Sénat c'est le contraire de
l'assemblée ces échanges ne sont pas
publics ensuite l'autre rendez-vous
c'est le 2 mars les débats commencent en
séance discussion générale examen
d'émotion examen des articles et des
amendements jusqu'aux 12 mars dernier
jour prévu par le calendrier petite
particularité au Sénat là encore les
débats auront lieu le week-end ce
n'était pas le cas à l'Assemblée les
débats n'étaient pas ouvert le week-end
vous l'avez vu j'ai dit jusqu'au 12 mars
ça veut dire qu'en plein milieu de
l'examen on trouve la journée de
mobilisation du 7 ou les syndicats
veulent mettre la France à l'arrêt une
date à noter donc et que se passe-t-il
si après le 12 mars dernier jour que le
texte soit voté ou non par le Sénat il
est envoyé en commission mixte paritaire
ou CMP c'est une réunion à huis clos
composés de 7 députés et de 7 sénateurs
désignaient selon l'importance de leur
groupe politique ils vont devoir
négocier point par point article par
article car cette commission a pour but
d'aboutir à une conciliation des deux
chambres sur un texte commun et merci
beaucoup Audrey pour ce calendrier
Olivier on commence avec vous le
gouvernement font beaucoup d'espoir sur
la forme au Sénat on va évidemment
parler du fond mais sur le fait qu'il
puisse y avoir des débats de fonds des
débats plus apaisés ils ont raison en
tout cas c'est la tradition au Sénat
alors l'écart avec l'Assemblée encore
plus flagrant depuis qu'il y a le groupe
insoumic a vraiment cette stratégie de
bruit de la fureur design époque j'en ai
que Mélenchon voilà donc le contraste
entre les deux devrait apparaître et
aussi beaucoup moins d'amendements qui
ont été déposés ce qui devrait permettre
d'examiner sinon la totalité en tout cas
beaucoup plus
articles et notamment le fameux article
7 qui est celui qui contient la mesure
la plus visible de ce projet de loi le
report de 62 à 64 ans de l'âge de l'âge
légal pour pour prendre sa retraite
sur la la forme mais ça rejoint aussi le
fond parce que on a l'impression qu'il y
a quand même deux stratégies Benjamin
sur les débat au scénario il y a d'un
côté la droite qui va aller jusqu'au
bout de l'examen du texte et voté sur
l'ensemble et de l'autre côté la gauche
qui veut voter l'article 7 qui n'était
pas cas de la France insoumise mais qui
veut pas forcément jusqu'au bout
exactement il y a une stratégie
d'opposition différente de celle de
l'Assemblée nationale à l'Assemblée
nationale la stratégie de la fi c'était
le mur d'amendement on bloque tout et on
espère que ça va craquer au sein de la
majorité que cette cocotte-minute de
l'Assemblée nationale bah va faire que
les députés de la majorité vont se
carapater en circonscription et que tout
d'un coup il va pouvoir y avoir des
majorités circonstancielles qui vont se
dessiner ça a pas marché là la stratégie
de la gauche au Sénat est très
différente c'est une stratégie plus
classique en réalité on vote jusqu'au
bout notamment on discute de l'article 7
et on essaye avec la droite quand même
et bien de modifier le texte de telle
façon à embêter le gouvernement mais
infini en vote pas la réforme pourquoi
bah parce que ça en fragilise la
légitimité parce qu'évidemment si c'est
très forme elle n'est votée dans aucune
chambre
mais c'est quand même LR qui a la main
toujours la tenue des débats parce qu'on
va dévoiler tout au long de ce club les
résultats de notre sondage au doxa pour
mictionnel la presse régionale 87% des
Français dont ce sondage veulent des
débats dignes et apaisés c'est au dessus
de 80% dans tous les partis et ce qui
est peut-être assez notable c'est que
c'est 94 % des sympathisants de la
France insoumise qui veulent des débats
d'ignapaisés oui un autre chiffre du
même sondage qui montre les
personnalités dont la cote est un peu en
recul les parmi les trois je sais pas
c'est les trois qui recrutent le plus en
tout cas vraiment en tête Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Adrien cadenas même si le
contexte c'est un petit peu particulier
le concernant et puis Sandrine Rousseau
qui fait pas partie des insoumis mais
qui fait partie de ces députés à gauche
qui font beaucoup d'agitations et
quelques esclandre et quelques coups
médiatiques parfois et donc ces trois-là
sont en recul il y a plus de défiance à
leur égard ça traduit ce que on a on
était nombreuses éditorialistes à dire
de façon instinctive que cette attitude
de la France insoumise et de mener le
combat de façon très violente au point
d'empêcher l'examen sur le fond d'une
bonne partie du texte à pas été très
apprécié en face on voit que des gens
comme Marine Le Pen ou Jordan mardella
même s'il est pas présent au Parlement
mais qui sont sur cette stratégie
d'opposition mais sur une ligne très
calme très respectable très posée au
point de venir au secours d'Olivier du
soft quand des propos durs ont été
assainés à son rencontre et eux au
contraire sont sur une trajectoire de
progression dans dans ce sondage ça
montre que les Français ne sont pas
raccords avec la stratégie de la France
insoumise le sondage audoxal j'aimerais
sur ce qui a été dit dans cette bataille
il y a deux blessés et un passager
clandestin les deux blessés c'est le
gouvernement et la France insoumise et
le passager clandestins en effet c'est
le RN qui a réussi en la matière sa
stratégie de crédibilisation avec une
stratégie en réalité tout bénéfice c'est
à dire que d'un côté et bien il y a eu
une opposition à cette réforme et donc
ce faisant et ben dans le sens de
l'opinion parce que ce que montre
également évidemment sondage c'est
qu'une grande majorité des Français est
opposée à cette réforme et de l'autre
côté et bien en ayant en profitant
également de l'obstruction parce que
c'est bien pratique d'avoir quelqu'un
qui fait l'obstruction pour vous ça
permet de montrer que vous opposez sans
pour autant être accusé de bloqué donc
là c'est en effet pour le rassemblement
national une victoire assez facile et en
effet la FIP RD points mais c'est comme
la question des blocages quand vous êtes
sur votre quai de RER et que vous
demandez pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas
de train et bien vous pouvez viser les
syndicats mais vous pouvez également
viser le gouvernement or si vous prenez
d'autres chiffres du sondage mais
également une enquête audoxale pour Le
Figaro dit à peu près une semaine vous
voyez que les le désordre à l'Assemblée
elle est fi n'en est pas le premier
responsable pour les Français c'est
d'abord le gouvernement et donc ce
faisant chacun voit un peu évidemment
midi à sa porte c'est à dire que
l'opposition va juger que c'est quand
même plutôt le gouvernement la majorité
que c'est plutôt la fi mais malgré tout
et bien le gouvernement sort affaibli de
cette séquence il aurait pu tenter de
capitaliser justement sur ce blocage
parfois un peu caricatural il faut le
dire de la fi il ne l'a pas réellement
fait que tout le gouvernement parce que
dans le sondage des personnalités
politiques en Gabriel Attal est assez
haut lui qui a porté la réforme à
l'Assemblée Olivier du socle lui en
revanche et très bas il y a une
différence pour les Français
négatives et en même temps il y a
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas tellement
d'avis sur lui donc c'est il y a aussi
une question visiblement de notoriété
oui Gabriel Attal s'en sort bien je veux
que j'ai pas d'explication particulière
là-dessus il y a une logique à ce que
les porteurs de la réforme Elizabeth
borne Olivier du Sud soit en baisse
sachant que les chiffres sur le le
l'appréciation globale du texte reste
très négatif autour des deux tiers je
crois d'opinion négatives
des des seuls ministres il y en avait
quelques-uns autorisés finalement à
défendre la réforme et il en a abusé si
on fait dire en tout cas il est allé
régulièrement à la rencontre des
Français à faire des réunions publiques
des fois devant 60 personnes pour
défendre la réforme c'est peut-être ça
finalement qui qui lui revient
positivement désormais
sur le fond c'est la suite vous en
parlez un peu Olivier de notre sondage
alors 70% des Français sont opposés au
vote de ce texte avec un report de l'âge
de départ mais en revanche 58% demande
au sénateurs de voter le texte sans
reporter l'âge
parce que les autres mesures ne sont là
un peu en tout cas dans du gouvernement
qu'on compensation de ce report de l'âge
légal de 62 à 64 ans donc là c'est sûr
que si on avait tout le texte sauf le
passage à 64 ans on a que les mesures
qui font plaisir on n'a pas celles qui
alors permettre de rapporter de l'argent
durant le gouvernement et qui consiste à
partir plus tard du monde du travail
bon mais certains c'est une réforme qui
fait plaisir à tout le monde dans ces
cas-là c'est plus facile à faire passer
effectivement ça
monte et son pas vous posez à une
réforme des retraites ils sont posés au
report de l'âge à 64 ans c'est ça que ça
qu'on peut en déduire
le problème c'est que la réforme des
retraites c'est essentiellement le
report de l'âge pour tout un tas de
réseaux qu'on peut éventuellement
expliquer parce que encore une fois et
je suis désolé d'être obsessionnel sur
mon droit constitutionnel mais PLFSS
donc ce faisant on peut pas modifier
d'éléments qui vont être structurants à
part cette question de l'âge donc en
effet le reste c'est peut-être on peut
considérer que c'est des mesures
importantes ou des mesures être que les
1200 euros minimum pour 10000 personnes
etc bah c'est une mesure majeure ou
c'est une mesure est ma priori en effet
ça fait plaisir à tout le monde on peut
pas être contre ça donc ce faisant ce
qui au moins transparaît dans l'opinion
ce qui apparaît relativement lisible
dans cette réforme c'est soit des
mesurettes soit la mesure d'âge vous
enlevez la mesure d'âge la plupart des
Français vont être pour en revanche si
vous envisagez une réforme plus
structurelle il est pas sûr que
l'opinion soit mûre si vous prenez les
enquêtes notamment sur la réforme de
2019-2020 qui n'avait rien à voir avec
celle-ci elle était très très différente
voyez que les enquêtes d'opinion
concernant cette réforme la précédente
sont à peu près stables en réalité on a
des variations qui passent et qui
concerne en réalité les mêmes électeurs
les mêmes français donc ce faisant
l'opposition en bloc à l'idée d'une
réforme des retraites quelle qu'elle
soit elle est quand même bien incrustée
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion et donc à
part une je dirais une réforme qui soit
une petite réforme qui fasse plaisir à
tout le monde on peut quand même
s'attendre à une opposition quand même
c'est très simple soit transformée
à cette réforme 66% très précisément le
gouvernement va pouvoir tenir alors je
pense qu'une question qui va peut-être
un peu changer la donne dans les deux
trois semaines qui viennent sans que ça
change cette appréciation d'ensemble
mais c'est la question des régimes
spéciaux
dont on voit bien Bruno Retailleau l'a
dit dans Le Parisien dimanche qu'il veut
pousser une accélération de cette remise
en cause des régimes spéciaux il
voudrait que ça s'applique au moins en
partie au personnel de la SNCF de la
RATP de dfgf qui sont
au travail en ce moment qui sont agents
en ce moment de ces entreprises et pas
seulement c'est ce qu'on appelle la
fameuse clause du grand-père et qui est
pour le moment ce que prévoit le texte
c'est à dire qu'on dit seuls les futurs
embauchés
seront au droit commun en matière de
retraite tous ceux qui travaillent déjà
continuent de garder ses règles
dérogatoires et favorables qui sont
celles qui existent actuellement donc
dire on va durcir ce passage de cette
fin des régimes spéciaux on va peut-être
l'appliquer à ceux qui travaillent déjà
c'est 2040 64 ans sur une une quinzaine
d'années c'est forcément renforcé la
capacité de mobilisation de ces
entreprises pour les semaines qui
viennent notamment puisqu'on va avoir
des mouvements reconductibles à la SNCF
à la RATP à partir du 7 mars maintenant
la question derrière ça c'est comment
l'opinion va réagir parce que
effectivement elle a jusqu'ici largement
soutenu de les syndicats mais les
régimes spéciaux ils sont pas très
populaires dans l'opinion donc si on
imagine le scénario et j'ai pas de boule
de cristal mais d'une France bloquée
assez fortement ou assez durablement et
que la question peut à peu dérive vers
celle des régimes spéciaux là peut-être
que le soutien de l'opinion au syndicat
peutroder ça peut être un élément qui
joue en faveur du gouvernement beaucoup
de sites dans ce que je dis mais c'est
une des hypothèses durcissement que
veulent faire les sénateurs LR sur
l'action d'un régime spéciaux alors oui
mais je suis pas sûr que ça favorise le
gouvernement pour plusieurs types de
raisons d'abord pensionnalité pas
évidente désolé encore une fois d'être
obsessionnel mais c'est pas tout à fait
évident on n'est pas certain sur la
chaîne spéciaux dans le cas d'un plfs
l'autre élément c'est que et ben si vous
prenez ça peut pas entrer dans les
économies
la logique de bonnet le fait qu'il faut
chercher des économies si vous prenez la
vie du Conseil d'État grosso modo la
question c'est est-ce que vraiment ça
joue sur l'année ou pas et donc là on a
une question parce qu'en fait c'est
vraiment inédit on fait pas de Ré des
retraites ou de réforme structurelles
par plfs d'habitude donc là il y a quand
même plusieurs éléments si le ronfabus
veut pas censurer globalement la réforme
et bien il y a quand même des chances
qu'il est en vie de faire un strike en
matière de cavalier socio si vous voulez
donc il y a quand même des risques sur
tout ce qui est introduit dans cette
réforme très clairement aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de réponse parce qu'on n'a pas
de précédent donc ce faisant il y a
quand même des risques l'autre élément
c'est que si vous prenez les précédents
95 et 2019-2020 vous voyez qu'en réalité
les régimes spéciaux ne posent pas
problème dès le moment enfin pour les
Français ne sont pas une forme de Casus
Belli contre les grévistes des moments
où il juge que la grève par procuration
est légitime parce qu'il juge que la
réforme est illégitime problématique etc
or l'opinion est déjà cristallisée en la
matière donc on peut penser qu'en effet
ça ne fera pas réellement bouger
l'opinion et que ce faisant il y aura
une forme d'enkystement le troisième
élément et là je rejoins tout à fait ce
qui a été dit c'est que pour l'instant
le petit espoir du gouvernement c'est
que cette grève elle soit finalement
assez peu suivie notamment dans les
transports tout bêtement parce que ceux
qui pourraient éventuellement avoir une
force de blocage donc faire de ces
grèves finalement et bien représentent
réellement un problème pour le
gouvernement et la majorité sont ceux
qui ne sont pas directement concernés
avec la clause du grand-père etc si vous
commencez à les mettre dans le viseur à
ce moment là ils vont se mobiliser et
une opinion qui soutient une
mobilisation forte structurelle et qui
porte là ça devient un vrai vrai
problème politique donc pas certain que
Elisabeth band soit particulièrement
heureuse des ambitions de Bruno
Retailleau et on va l'écouter dans
quelques instants les régimes spéciaux
qui pourraient être dans le viseur
puisque c'est l'article 1 qui est étudié
à partir du 2 après la discussion
générale sachant que la grande journée
de mobilisation c'est le 7 donc cet
article sera étudiant et justement on va
en parler puisqu'il y a lors de sa
visite au salon de l'agriculture
Elisabeth borne a parlé de la réforme
des retraites et de cette journée du 7
mars elle a lancé un appel à la
responsabilité au syndicat
la resp
onsabilité
faire des crêpes et notamment du set et
ensuite je pense que c'est aussi que
chacun prenne en compte la nécessité des
Françaises se déplacer
cette appel à la responsabilité comme le
dit Elisabeth borne Olivier alors il y a
deux choses il y a le fait de bloquer le
pays
là d'abord faut bien savoir que les les
syndicats au sein des entreprises RATP
et SNCF sont largement autonomes par
rapport aux confédérations donc je suis
pas sûr qu'un Laurent Berger un Philippe
Martinez et beaucoup de poids sur ce que
décidant ce moment leurs affiliés dans
dans ces entreprises surtout Philippe
Martinez qui en plus c'est en fin de
mandat il y a un congrès et en plus on
ne sait pas qui va lui succéder c'est
c'est là dans un mois donc ça c'est un
petit peu
ils peuvent être débordés sur une
hypothèse sur l'autre point de la
responsabilité je trouve que c'est un
discours assez
culotté entre guillemets de la part
d'Elizabeth borne parce que c'est un des
points qui sont demander aux
organisations syndicales depuis le début
de ce conflit c'est la façon extrêmement
bordée cadrée sage sans incident dans ce
passent les manifestations depuis trois
ou quatre fois maintenant et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est dans le crédit est
donné aux organisations syndicales donc
de ce point de vue là elles ont plutôt
fait preuve de responsabilité depuis le
début sur cet appel si vous voulez la
question c'est toujours la même je me
replace dans mon image de tout à l'heure
je suis sur mon quai de RER et vous
voyez le traumatisme notamment de 2019
pour aller donner mes cours donc oui il
y a un traumatisme je suis sur mon quai
de RER et il y a pas de train pourquoi
qui est responsable soit c'est les
syndicats parce qu'en effet il se
battent pour leurs pommes soit c'est le
gouvernement parce que la réforme est
illégitime parce que le gouvernement
s'entête et parce que elle était
peut-être pas nécessaire cette réforme à
tort ou à raison je prends pas parti sur
le fond mais aujourd'hui quand vous
prenez les enquêtes et bien les Français
sont plutôt sur l'autre option et donc
ce faisant si j'attends mon quai de sur
mon quai de RER c'est à la fin du
gouvernement les syndicats font ce qu'il
faut tant pis et le gouvernement devrait
arrêter de s'entêter et retirer sa
réforme qui est la cause de mon blocage
c'est ça en fait le problème du
gouvernement actuel c'est que si les
blocages apparaissent populaire
aujourd'hui comme en 2020 c'est qu'il
est perçu comme et bien présentant une
mesure qui est bloquante et qui donc est
illégitime et donc arriver à renverser
l'opinion là-dessus est compliqué si
vous écoutez Emmanuel Macron au salon du
GRU culture l'autre jour il dit bah
voilà cette réforme de toute façon elle
va passer c'est un changement de
stratégie rhétorique grosso modo ce
qu'il dit c'est légitime pas légitime
populaire pas populaire c'est pas mon
problème de toute façon ça va passer
quoi qu'il arrive donc si vous attendez
sur votre quai de RER c'est parce que
certains s'entêtent parce que au fond
quoi qu'il arrive je dirais c'est déjà
écrit donc c'est un changement de pied
stratégique ça convaincra personne sur
le fond de la réforme tout du moins
personne qui n'est déjà convaincu mais
c'est une façon et bien de marginaliser
cette position qui est vu comme inutile
à voir si ça fonctionne et ça rejoint un
peu c'est la stratégie qui était celle
de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2010 quand on est
passé de l'âge de 60 à 62 ans c'est la
réforme verte il y avait une très forte
opposition régulière répétée massive de
toutes les organisations syndicales la
réforme est passée infinie il y a quand
même une différence c'est qu'à l'époque
il disposait d'une majorité absolue ce
qui n'est pas le cas du gouvernement
aujourd'hui évidemment et on va voir sur
le soutien à cette journée du 7 mars
c'est toujours le sondage auto que ça
61% des Français soutiennent cette
journée 54% des Français soutiennent des
grèves reconductibles au delà du 7 mars
ça veut dire que l'opinion elle est
claire pour le moment on soutient on
syndicat oui pour le moment alors après
c'est toujours un peu la différence dans
sur ce type de question entre la théorie
et la pratique c'est à dire que on verra
si on repose la question et s'il y a des
blocages forts et persistants au bout de
quatre jours cinq jours une semaine
est-ce que le soutien sera toujours
aussi massif vous savez c'est un peu
comme sur le même thème de la réforme
des retraites quand on demande aux gens
est-ce que il faut réformer les retrait
raites sur le principe oui approbation
massive et puis quand on commence à
rentrer dans le détail et notamment
est-ce que je vais moi partir plus tard
là les chiffres sont pas exactement les
mêmes donc le syndrome du quai de RER on
va voir comment il joue au bout de au
bout de quelques jours et
en plus que et c'est le dernier
enseignement de de ce sondage la
popularité du couple exécutif Emmanuel
Macron Élisabeth borne Emmanuel Macron
64% de mauvaise opinions et les abeilles
Bormes 69% de mauvaises opinions on peut
faire une telle réforme dans ces
conditions c'est compliqué c'est
évidemment extrêmement compliqué parce
que vous avez ces conditions sont d’agir
qui rappelle un petit peu la cote de
popularité d'Emmanuel Macron au moment
des gilets jaunes alors pas au pire
moment mais quand même au moment de la
crise des gilets jaunes ce qui était le
grand trou du précédent quinquennat en
termes de popularité de l'autre côté il
y a quand même quelques différences par
rapport à l'époque on est dans une crise
économique qui est une crise larvée on
va avoir un mois de mars très très
difficile et je ne suis pas sûr que même
si je pète contre ma paroisse et qu'il
faut la faire un jour je suis pas sûr
que la réforme des institutions soit
vraiment la priorité pour qu'ensuite les
Français se disent on tourne la page et
de l'autre côté comme ça bien été dit il
y a une majorité non seulement relative
mais en plus très je dirais très divisé
entre le modem horizon les différentes
tendances de la majorité donc la cote de
popularité difficile cette réforme qui
n'est tout autant une perspective
compliquée et pas vraiment de
perspective de réforme qui réunissent la
majorité derrière ça fait que la suite
de cette réforme qui devrait enfin d'un
point de vue purement procédural il y a
pas de raison qu'elle passe pas elle
passera au Sénat CMP ensuite qui peut y
avoir un usage du 49 alinéa 3 donc le
gouvernement s'il veut aller jusqu'au
bout peut aller jusqu'au bout mais les
dégâts en termes d'opinion les dégâts au
sein de sa propre majorité risque d'être
très très difficile à colmater
oui de ce point de vue là ce sera pas du
tout la même chose si effectivement il y
a d'abord à votre positif au Sénat puis
une approbation de la version finale du
texte par l'Assemblée
ou alors si on a quelque chose qui se
termine un petit peu en haut d'un au
Sénat comme ça s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale puis une adoption par le 49-3
ça donne évidemment pas la même force la
même assise la même légitimité face à la
rue qui conteste ça change totalement
les équilibres donc
le texte malgré tout toutes les chances
d'être adoptées mais si il est adopté un
petit peu au forcing comme ça ça peut se
payer ensuite sur d'autres textes sur
d'autres thèmes sur d'autres réformes
sur lesquels cette fois-ci le l'opinion
est peut-être certain dans la majorité
pourraient dire cette fois-ci stop c'est
la goutte de trop ça veut dire que le
pire c'est pour après après cette
réforme après le vote de cette réforme
pour l'exécuter ça pourrait l'être si
elle est de si elle est adoptée dans des
conditions en ayant recours à ces
instruments qui sortent son
constitutionnel mais qui qui relève du
passage en force on a vu toutes les fois
sur le budget le budget de la Sécu ou le
gouvernement a dû délégué ce 49-3 ça
donne un argument supplémentaire aux
opposants pour dire que
voilà il y a eu passage en force et pour
contester la légitimité même si encore
tout cela est juridiquement absolument
border incontestable fait partie des
règles constitutionnelles
oui c'est à dire que le danger il a en
effet pour la pré c'est à dire que on va
avoir une majorité qui va être une
grande partie fragilisée des structuré
on va avoir une cote de popularité du
chef de l'État qui va demeurer dans des
eaux relativement basse et on a une
opinion chauffée à blanc par la par la
crise économique donc très très
clairement ce passage de la réforme des
retraites c'est un cap pour le
gouvernement l'après se dessine de
manière absolument pas évidente c'est à
dire que encore une fois les textes les
réformes qui sont envisagés que ce soit
sur les institutions l'immigration sont
des textes qui en soi ne sont pas
prioritairement la préoccupation des
Français actuellement qui se retrouvent
face à une crise énergétique et une
crise économique donc on est dans une
forme de grand grand inconnu la question
de jours d'après va vraiment se poser
pour le gouvernement et pour l'instant
rien n'est réglé
ça commence cet après-midi en commission
et ça dure au moins jusqu'au 12 mars
Audrey
[Musique]